on the morning of march 15th ola went
looking for her son
and this is what she found
the charred remains of his vehicle and
her son in the driver's seat
attacked i put my son's remains into a
bag and carried them on my back she says
she then walked 15 kilometers to bury
him here in the backyard
[Music]
her son's friend told her they were
driving a shipment of aid to their
russian occupied town when they were
attacked by a russian tank
she returned to the scene this week
joined by a team of police and forensics
experts tasked with investigating
russian war crimes
the prosecutor says they're
investigating more than a dozen war
crimes on the outskirts of harkiev all
involving civilians killed while under
russian occupation
a war crime is any instance where
civilians are deliberately targeted for
example this apartment building blown
apart by two bombs allegedly dropped by
a russian warplane nine people were
killed and this is now being
investigated as a possible war crime
residents say the bomb's impact
shattered windows and turned shards of
glass into projectiles
my grandchildren were covered in blood
they were rushed to the hospital this
resident says
along with targeting civilians war
crimes can also be linked to a
particular weapon
in this town a few hours south the mayor
shows us neighborhoods riddled with
these shrapnel pellets like the kind
found in cluster munitions
cluster bombs typically disperse in the
air spreading smaller bombs
indiscriminately over a large area
they're banned by most countries but
global news saw evidence of cluster
submunitions in several areas
[Applause]
the whole town is like this the mayor
says with a pre-war population of nine
thousand barbinkova has no military
infrastructure or strategic value
eleven people have been killed here
including children
they're targeting civilians the mayor
says there isn't a single street in our
town where homes haven't been hit
on this nearby road a resident returned
to find her house destroyed she
collected these fragments from a russian
rocket
i don't understand why the russians are
doing this she said we will never
forgive them
jeff semple global news harkev ukraine